let's continue taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 let's go to our next caller from
the 484 area code caller from 484 what's
your name and where you're calling from
my name is Xavier and I'm calling from
Pennsylvania cool what's on your mind
today well I have a question regarding
the death penalty I know that there are
plenty of arguments against what that
penalty like the morality of it and also
to protect them accidentally executing
an innocent but I was wondering what is
your idea on prisoners with a license
should have the option to request
assisted suicide well the question is
should they have the right to request
assistance suicide in circumstances
where someone not in prison would not be
able to request assisted suicide right
because you're not saying a prisoner who
is terminally ill and has for example
under six months to live as some state
laws say requesting assisted suicide
you're saying any prisoner who has a
life sentence could at any time say I
want to be killed essentially is that
what you're suggesting yeah yeah pretty
much just like the idea that you know
that that cellie some an option you're
giving in just in case that there is an
innocent there there at least not being
executed at least have that option
yeah I'm against that I think that if
we're going to talk about assisted
suicide then there should be specific
rules under which it can be done under a
sueance supervision and states that have
legalized assisted suicide have
established that and generally it's some
sense of you know doctors sign off and
there's a sort of I think in some cases
a to doctor consensus that this is
someone who has no more than six months
left to live because of a medical
condition etc I I don't think that there
should be this sort of blanket where
anybody with a life sentence can request
assisted suicide and now Xavier is there
difference in your mind if someone has
the possibility of parole versus doesn't
have it would this only be for people
who do not have the possibility of
parole or for anybody with a life
sentence even if they could be paroled
well I mean I guess the reason I was
asking because it was also like the
argument of whether in what's worse
execution or life in prison and that
sometimes will stumps me too
I get you know what I mean yeah I mean I
happen to think that so what we've
gotten mixed up with this in the past
with some callers Pat where I don't
actually think that we should determine
whether or not to have the death penalty
based on whether it's the worst possible
punishment that I don't think that
that's the standard we should apply or
based on what they want or don't want or
based on what they want or don't want
right however I've said that if you
support the death penalty because you
think it's the worst possible punishment
I happen to believe that life in prison
without parole is actually worse but I
don't actually think that's a good way
to decide whether that penalty should be
legal because it's completely subjective
and one person would prefer to just be
in car serrated for their entire life
another person would just want the easy
way out no doubt about it
alright so Savior yeah I'm against that
but I do think that if you're in prison
in a state that has legalized assisted
suicide for medical conditions you
should certainly have access to that
alright thanks for the call I appreciate
it yeah all right well yeah I'll let you
show thanks again thanks very much